♪ ♪
>> Kayleigh: HELLO, EVERYONE.
THIS IS MONDAY AND THIS IS
"OUTNUMBERED."
I AM KAYLEIGH McENANY IN 20 ME
KENNEDY, DR. NICOLE SAPHIER,
MORGAN ORTAGUS AND TODD PIRO.
29 DAYS, THAT IS IT UNTIL THE
TERM ELECTIONS ARRIVED.
BUT INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
VOTERS HERE AT HOME, GUESS WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING?
THEY ARE TAKING THEIR
FUND-RAISING EFFORTS OVERSEAS.
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN
ADAM SCHIFF AND NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN SEAN PATRICK MALONEY
WERE SPOTTED SIPPING WINE AND
EATING HORS D'OEUVRES ON A
BALCONY AT ANY PLANT IN PARIS,
FRANCE.
THEY STAYED AT A SWANKY
HOTEL, OF COURSE, TO
FUND-RAISING FROM DEMOCRATS
LIVING ABROAD.
MIKE WALLER THE REPUBLICAN
INCUMBENT WITH MALONEY TWEETED A
PICTURE OF MALONEY WITH HIS
QUOTE "JAUNT TO PARIS,
SWITZERLAND AND LONDON."
WALLACE HAS BEEN SPEAKING ACROSS
THE DISTRICT INSTEAD OF
GALLIVANTING AROUND THE GLOBE.
I MEAN, KENNEDY, WE LOVE WINE
AND HORS D'OEUVRES AND PARIS,
FRANCE, AND SWITZERLAND, BUT
AMERICA IS SUFFERING FROM
CRIPPLING INFLATION, GAS PRICES
AND ARMAGEDDON.
>> Kennedy: AND LOOK AT THIS
AND I LOOK AT THESE CONGRESSMAN
AND I THINK, READ THE ROOM.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONSTITUENTS
THINKING?
AND NOT EVERYTHING IS A CASH
GRAB IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN POWER.
THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
DISTRICT WHO ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME BUYING GROCERIES WHO ARE
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT THEIR KIDS
ARE BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS?
LOOK AT THE UNCERTAINTY IN
PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
BORDER.
THESE TWO PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
POSTS HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH PEOPLE NOT
ONLY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY BUT PEOPLE IN THEIR
DISTRICTS WHO ARE BEING SQUEEZED
IN THE MIDDLE.
I HOPE IT WAS FUN.
I HOPE IT IS WORTH IT AND I HOPE
THEY GET VOTED OUT TO.
>> Kayleigh: I DO TOO, THE
RESPONSE WAS REALLY INTERESTING.
CHAIRMAN MALONEY ON A TEN DAY
FUND-RAISING RAISING MONEY FOR
CANDIDATES TO STOP MAGA
REPUBLICANS WHO WANT TO PASS
NATIONAL ABORTION BAN FROM
GAINING CONTROL IN CONGRESS.
YOU COMPARE THAT TO LEADER
McCARTHY, 25 STATES HAS BEEN A
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT SINCE
AUGUST WHICH HAPPENED TO BE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Kennedy: I THINK THIS IS A
SIGN DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP HAS
GIVEN UP, ESPECIALLY IN THE
HEALTH OF THE MIDTERMS.
THERE IS NO WAY YOU WOULD GO
OVERSEAS IF YOU ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT TRYING TO KEEP THE
MAJORITY.
THERE IS NO WAY.
I'M WORKING WITH CANDIDATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY ON NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES, AND YOU CAN GET
THEM OUT OF THE DISTRICT.
YOU CAN'T GET THEM OUT OF THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY ARE FIGHTING
TOOTH AND NAIL TO WIN.
WE HAVE THEM SIPPING CHAMPAGNE,
OKAY, WHITE WINE IN PARIS AND WE
ALSO HAVE NANCY PELOSI AND HER
TEAM LOOKING AS SOON AS SHE IS
KICKED OUT, SHE WOULD LIKE TO BE
AMBASSADOR TO ITALY.
FOR ME WHO KNOWS CAMPAIGNS AND
POLITICS, THIS IS A SIGN THEY
ARE GIVING UP ON THE MAJORITY.
>> Kayleigh: THAT IS AT A
FANCY POINT WITH NANCY PELOSI
GOING OVER THESE FOR A NUMBER OF
TRIPS.
DR. SAPHIER, RIGHT HERE AT HOME,
YOU HAVE LEE ZELDIN AND I SAW
THIS LAST NIGHT IN THE PRESS
CONFERENCE AND THERE WERE
GUNSHOTS BY HIS HOUSE AND HIS
WIFE WERE NOT TAKEN BUT TAKE A
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> THEY WERE AT THE KITCHEN
TABLE.
THEY WERE DOING HOMEWORK.
ALL HOMEWORK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY ARE
MULTIPLE GUNSHOTS.
THEY HEAR SCREAMING THERE
SCREAMING AND THEY GO UPSTAIRS
AND LOCK THEMSELVES IN THE
BATHROOM.
ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS CALLED 911
AND THE OTHER DAUGHTER CALLS US.
YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE WHO GOT SHOT
ESSENTIALLY LAYING DOWN 10 FEET
FROM WHERE THEY WERE DOING
HOMEWORK.
ONE OF THE BULLETS LANDED
30 FEET FROM WHERE THE GIRLS
WERE DOING HOMEWORK.
YEAH, THIS HITS EXTREMELY CLOSE
TO HOME TO SHOW UP AT HER
DOORSTEP HERE OR ARE A LOT OF
FAMILIES AND PARENTS DEALING
WITH THIS REALITY OF RISING
CRIME IN NEW YORK FOR US.
UNFORTUNATELY, MY DAUGHTERS KNEW
HOW TO RESPOND BUT THEY WERE
SITTING AT THE KITCHEN TABLE
DOING HOMEWORK AND BULLETS FOR
STARTED GOING OFF ALL AROUND
THEM.
>> Kayleigh: THAT WAS FROM
THIS MORNING ON "FOX & FRIENDS"
AND A PRESS CONFERENCE IN IT WAS
JARRING TO SEE A NOMINEE FOR A
MAJOR PARTY FACING A DEMOCRAT
WHO DOESN'T CARE ABOUT CRIME
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT GUNSHOTS NEAR
FEET FROM HIS DAUGHTER WHERE THE
VICTIMS WERE.
>> KAYLEIGH, IT HAPPENED SUNDAY
AFTERNOON 2:00 P.M.
AND NOT JUST A DEMOCRAT THAT HE
LIKE NEW YORK CITY OR
SAN FRANCISCO AND NEW ORLEANS
AND ALL THESE OTHER PLACES, BUT
THE SUBURBS OF LONG ISLAND.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW JUST
LIKE WHEN WE STARTED SENDING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO THE BORDER
UP TO THE DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
MAYBE YOU NEED TO HAVE VIOLENCE
COME OUT TO WHAT WE ONCE
CONSIDERED SAFER SUBURBS FOR
PEOPLE TO START PAYING
ATTENTION.
NOW LEE ZELDIN HAS HAD TOUGH ON
CRIME STANCES AND THE FACT HIS
ATTACKER FROM THE SUMMER GOT LET
OUT WITHOUT BAIL BECAUSE SOFT ON
CRIME...
THE VERY NEXT DAY AND THE FACT
THAT NOW THIS BULLET LANDED
30 FEET FROM HIS DAUGHTER AND
THE SAFETY OF THEIR OWN
HOME, YOU CAN SURE AS KNOW HE
WILL NOT BE SOFT ON CRIME
IF HE IS ELECTED GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE.
MAYBE YOU ACTUALLY NEED TO SEE
SOME OF THESE VIOLENT CRIMES GO
TO THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION OR THE
EXECUTIVE MANSION WHERE KATHY
HOCHUL GETS TO SIT AND REMIND
ALL HER PROPERTIES ARE IN
UPSTATE NEW YORK NOWHERE NEAR
THIS CRIME HAPPENED.
>> WE DON'T WANT VIOLENCE
PERPETRATED NEAR ANY POLITICIAN
REGARDLESS.
THE >> Dr. Saphier: THANK YOU,
KENNEDY, THAT IS NOT WHAT I'M
CALLING FOR AT ALL BUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE SIT IN THE SUBURBS FEELIG
LIKE THEY ARE SAFE IN THE CRIME
THAT WE SEE AND THEY WILL NEVER
GET TO THEIR FRONT DOOR.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
WE SEE AS I MENTIONED THE
MIGRANTS BEING SHIPPED TO THE
SMALLER TOWNS THAT HAVE NEVER
DEALT WITH ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
AND IMMIGRATION AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY ARE TRYING TO FIX
IT.
MAYBE THAT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN.
PEOPLE TO START TAKING THE
INCREASE IN VIOLENT CRIME
SERIOUSLY.
IT WILL NOT JUST BE IN THE URBAN
CITIES BUT ALL OF US, BIG AND
SMALL TOWNS.
>> Kayleigh: TWO RANDOM
ATTACKS.
AND HEY, THIS WAS NOT TARGETED
TO HIS DAUGHTERS COME UP THAT
MAKES IT ALMOST WORSE.
THIS WAS RANDOM CRIME THAT
HAPPENED.
THIS WAS NOT A TARGETED
POLITICAL ATTACK AND NOT JUST
HAPPENING TO EVERYONE WERE
LEE ZELDIN BUT NEW YORK CITY
PERIODS READ FIVE GNOMIC
>> Todd: I WORRY THIS IS THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I DID A LITTLE PUSHBACK BUT AT
THIS .2022, NO PLACE IS SAFE IN
AMERICA ANYMORE.
THAT IS A SCARY PROPOSITION.
WHEN I GO HOME, I ASSUME IN
CONNECTICUT I AM SAFE.
BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE ELITIST
DEMOCRAT AND PARISIAN COCKTAIL
PARTIES WHILE THE REST OF US TRY
TO SURVIVE IN USED OPIUM AMERICA
LITERALLY FIGHTING FOR OUR LIVES
WHEN IT COMES TO CRIME.
AS FOR THE CRIME ASPECT OF
LEE ZELDIN'S PLATFORM, BOY,
POLITICALLY THIS WAS A GREAT
MOVE TO HAVE HAPPENED TO HIM.
IN A DAY IN HIS POSITION KNOWS
YOU WOULD NEVER MAKE THAT
EXCHANGE IN A DAY OF THE WEEK.
AND YOU CAN SEE SHAKEN BY THIS
BECAUSE IT INVOLVED HIS TWO
DAUGHTERS.
WITH SOMEBODY WITH TWO DAUGHTERS
MYSELF BOY, WHEN I HOP IN THE
CAR AND GO TO WORK, I WORRY I'M
LEAVING MY FAMILY TO WORK.
HE LEFT HIS FAMILY AND THAT'S
EVERY FATHER'S WORST NIGHTMARE.
AND I HOPE THE PEOPLE OF
NEW YORK WAKE UP IN RELATION
NEED TO ELECT PEOPLE THAT WILL
KEEP THAT STEP FROM HAPPENING.
>> Kayleigh:
KENNEDY, THANK GOD THEY ARE OKAY
BUT THIS IS NOT ONE LUNATIC IN
THE POLITICAL ATTACK.
THIS HAPPENS TO SO MANY PEOPLE.
I HAVE SEEN A 1-YEAR-OLD IN A
COFFIN HERE IN NEW YORK TWO
YEARS AGO.
THIS IS HAPPENING, IT SEEMS LIKE
DAILY.
WE HAVE CHILDREN ON TARGET, OF
RANDOM ATTACK AND IT IS GETTING
WORSE.
>> Kennedy: I HAVE TO GIVE THE
CONGRESSMAN CREDIT BECAUSE
HE, OBVIOUSLY, HAVE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH HIS CHILDREN
AND HIS FAMILY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE PARENTS
CAN INTERNALIZE FROM THIS WHEN
THERE IS GUNFIRE, DON'T GO OUT
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
IS.
LOCK YOURSELF IN A SAFE PLACE
AND CALL 911.
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
OBVIOUSLY, A BEAUTIFUL FAMILY
AND SMART GIRLS.
TO YOUR POINT, THIS IS HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE.
IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE BEING
ATTACKED FROM ALL SIDES.
AND POLITICIANS, THEY WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE INFLATION.
THEY WON'T ACKNOWLEDGE THERE ARE
BAD PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO SHOULD
BE KEPT OFF OF THE STREETS.
THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE
INCARCERATED WHO SHOULD BE LET
OUT.
IT IS SO COMPLETELY OUT OF
BALANCE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS, PEOPLE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION TO POLITICS.
THESE ARE THOSE ISSUES, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT CLEMENT AND WITH THESE